President Trump has declared a national
emergency at the US border with Mexico
mr. Trump says this allows him to get
billions of dollars that Congress
refused to give him to build a wall
there but the president is facing sharp
criticism about his decision and he says
he expects a long legal battle and we
will then be sued and they will sue us
in the Ninth Circuit even though it
shouldn't be there and we will possibly
get a bad ruling and then we'll get
another bad ruling and then we'll end up
in the Supreme Court and hopefully we'll
get a fair shake and we'll win in the
Supreme Court president Trump says the
wall is needed to stop what he claims is
a flow of drugs criminals and illegal
immigrants coming into the country here
to talk more about that is Caitlin
Dickerson immigration reporter for The
New York Times Caitlin welcome thank you
so is this more political emergency or a
national emergency because it took
several weeks if not months and years in
office for the President to declare this
a national emergency I think it depends
how you look at this issue president
Trump and many of his supporters clearly
do see it as an emergency but I don't
think when they say that they mean
something new as you pointed out
immigration is is not a new concept at
all and actually illegal immigration to
the country is down but the fact is that
President Trump campaigned on this
promise to build a border wall it's one
of the most popular things that he said
and that's why you hear him repeat it so
often and that's why he was really boxed
into a corner right because as much as
he felt the need to deliver on this
promise he found that it became very
difficult to get Congress to support it
and Congress controls the power of the
purse so he was really boxed in in terms
of how to move forward and I think
that's how we got to where we are today
the national emergency was really the
only way that he could describe this
issue and could use this issue legally
in order to get it paid for so you've
actually been to one of those border
cities El Paso recently what can you
tell us about what we're you're really
seeing there on the ground sure so just
to situate people El Paso is on the
border in West Texas is right below New
Mexico and it's a very immigrant heavy
it's a it's a very highly trap
back to port it's very busy and I think
it's one of those classic border cities
that you hear about quite often where
people move back and forth along the
border every day you know my uber driver
one day told me he lives in Ciudad
Juarez in Mexico because he it's more
affordable and then he crosses the
border every day to work are you seeing
any of what the president is talking
about or describing no I mean I would
say one of the most surprising things
maybe maybe the most surprising thing
about President Trump State of the Union
address was this idea he put forth that
El Paso had been one of the dangerous
most dangerous cities in the country
before a wall was constructed there a
fence was constructed there about a
decade ago it's just not true and you
just don't see it borne out every day
it's a very safe city I mean let's not
pretend that there's no impact on El
Paso from immigration it's true that
when people are processed through the
immigration system and they're released
there's an effect on the local
healthcare system for a few days
typically then people move on to their
destinations within the US but really
what I saw more than anything was a safe
city one that's been that way for
decades and one that really rallies
around the immigrant community so the
sort of volunteer work that's needed to
help support the new immigrants there's
no shortage of in Congress did pass a
bipartisan agreement a border security
package not money for a wall but but
what is in there
so the border security package I think
one of the reasons that you saw Congress
be able to come together in a rare
instance and pass it is that it's not
terribly controversial or surprising you
saw some additional money for the Border
Patrol facilities that are in remote
areas those are the types of facilities
that the two young migrant children have
passed through during Christmastime who
died and I think those those deaths drew
a lot of you know needed attention to
those facilities that needed some
support in addition to that you see some
more money for health care and
infrastructure and you see money for
additional ice detention beds so I think
that was probably one of the most
contentious things is that well we've
all been focused on the border and
asylum in the wall interior enforcement
those interior arrests have continued to
go really strong some that it's not
getting reported as often and I think
it's because we're inundated I think you
know the public isn't inundated and
quite frankly journalists are inundated
because that so much has changed I
covered immigration for years and this
has just been an incredibly busy period
where it becomes difficult to cover
everything with the degree of you know
urgency that it requires Caitlyn
Dickerson thank you so much brilliant
points made thank you so much